everyone knows who's influencing
politics the
rich people yup just make it stop
he trump was probably the closest you
were gonna get to that his notion of
draining the swamp but then you saw how
deep the swamp goes
goes back years and years some rich guy
that comes in that's
uh you know a tv star isn't going to
shift that thing they hated him
so much trump's biggest problem i think
was that he didn't
drain the swamp yeah he said he was
going to and the twitter stuff
he could have been so much better if he
just kept his tweets to himself
it would have been way better 50 50.
okay some some of the tweets
circumvented media lies and a lot of
hilarious too oh man you know my
favorite tweet is
okay because the people who watch know
this was when elizabeth warren was doing
that really awful live stream
do you remember that yeah and she's like
i'm gonna get me a beer yeah and then
she like goes and get a beer
her husband walks up and he like smacks
her on the ice
and she's like and i'm like wow that was
like a really bad moment for a
presidential campaign yeah
but sure fine i guess it's the husband
and wife but she goes i'm glad you're
here
trump tweeted she said elizabeth
warren's husband comes in he says i'm
glad you're here he's supposed to be
there
he lives there it was
it's such an amazing tweet because it
was like something you'd hear
uh you're at your friend's place and his
dad's in there and it was just
it wasn't about politics it wasn't about
policy or
you know party or anything he was just
pointing out an absurdity and that was
really funny
he was so funny shane gillis had this
joke when shane got fired
he came back right away and jumped right
into the stuff shane gillis if you don't
know
is a brilliant comic and you see
he saturday night live would have helped
him inevitably but he's gonna make it no
matter what
shane had this joke where he just goes
you know people complain about and he
goes i didn't vote for trump
but for those that are listening yeah
aaron winked i winked very
at him very succinctly and he goes but
he's hilarious he's funnier than
95 of the community he goes he goes if
he came on after
me he would bury me he'd be like look at
that gay
not funny fat he was fired
and it was right after the snl firing
and it was just such a great topical
joke
i got invited to the white house and uh
the sub shop
in atlantic city yes yeah no no i got i
got invited to the white house it was
the
it was the the white house social media
summit okay and i was like
finally you know in 2018 i said
republicans were too stupid the
politicians too stupid to deal with
social media censorship to save their
own
you know positions and i was right i
like that you brought that up as a
subject and then said positions instead
of the word you wanted to say but
well i'm like wait no i mean like
they're jobs
okay they got it or their lives whatever
but to save their own jobs they didn't
realize they were getting crushed with
social media censorship their supporters
and fans were being
ripped away and so i said that in 2018
surprisingly
you know i actually thought republicans
were still going to win and they lost
and i was like well there you go i guess
i got half of it right
so i get invited to this white house
summit i'm all excited like finally the
republicans
are going to do something about this and
do you know what i got to experience
instead of a serious and legitimate
conversation about social media
censorship a little cocktail party where
they want everybody to be nice and
donald trump doing an hour of stand up
come on
legit come on it was hilarious i want to
hit the table
oh great hilarious just him
it was so it was did he have an opener i
think he did who was but it was a really
boring like
i i think he had an opener i just don't
remember because it didn't matter
because trump
basically did stand up i'm telling you
trump did stand up trump does stand up
his rallies
are almost stand up yes this crowd work
he'll do a bit and then he'll walk away
from the mic
which is a weird thing that's that's a
very urban comic thing to do
the room was like i was a couple hundred
of trump's most ardent supporters
oh i wish i could i was the only one not
wearing a suit i'm wearing this
and people are laughing like tim pool
shows up everyone's in a suit but him
and i was like because i'm here for like
look i'm not gonna wear a suit it's not
what i'm here for
serious matter and we need to get
something happening well i'm like listen
listen
look at this guy with his two gun yeah
so
in that's a canadian word by the way
duke is a very canadian no no but i'm
like in america people ask me about i'm
like in america
you can be some regular dude going to
the white house and speaking your mind
you know
you don't got to be somebody who owns a
suit right that's why i like this
country i can show up in the white house
wearing my normal clothes
and that's what america's about i don't
got to put on my formal address to tire
my awards my pins or anything i can be
an american saying listen up this
matters
now there was some serious nature to it
but i got to tell you man i sat there
and at first i was kind of getting let
down by what was going on
and then i just started just rolling
with it i'm like this guy's hilarious
yeah he jokes about himself being orange
yeah he's like the lights
it's not my fault they call me orange
but they put on the d everyone's
laughing
they get it yeah they're they're
self-aware and it's funny how
you know when the left tries to make fun
of trump they use the exact same state
jokes he's overweight orange and his
small hands and i'm like dude
trump's already used that bit in stand
up you can't just keep saying it
the joke's done yeah these people are
stealing trump's bit it was all they had
he was great with crowd i mean it wasn't
great there's a handful of comics that
are great i
i mean i believe i'm i'm one of the best
crowd work comics around big jokerson
david tell there's a few but he was
fun for his level of experience look at
this guy he's ugly
what's he doing here and when he does
that y'all thing like
the fake news yeah you see this woman
fat woman i tell you she has no idea
what she's and he does things like
it's a very borst battle style of guy i
tell you take my wife
please it's like he had this rodney
dangerfield kind of asteroid
because he his favorite comic and he
will disavow this now
was jeff ross he loved ross and ross
loved playing with him and then as soon
as he got in ross was like
yeah yeah and i loved jeff ross but he
had his moment where he's like i got him
do you remember
in in the 2016 cycle when megan kelly
was like
you've called women yeah pigs he goes
only rosie o'donnell
and the crowd erupts yeah and it was
like
they did and it was at a time when she's
attacking him and you think that they're
gonna jump on it he turns it into a joke
she's bleeding from everywhere i don't
know
the phone call that was a phone call
from her eyes or you know whatever
he just like outside of that stuff trump
needed to get his switch under control
but i think
if you're somebody who is just
tribalistic
i think there's a lot of people who are
scared didn't want to fall out of line
with the tribe
they're worried about being ostracized
or shunned or fired or whatever so they
just say oh yeah i hate trump too
then there are a lot of people who are
just blind zealots who are like trump is
bad
but the people who are interested in
actually listening what he had to say we
hear so many stories with people walking
away from the democratic party
when they finally decided to just watch
a trump video
because they learned that the media was
lying
and they also laughed and they were like
that's not what they were like the media
was saying he said this that and this
and i watched the speech and it was
actually just
like him cracking jokes and like yeah he
didn't say those things sure they took a
lot of stuff out of context people
basically everything didn't like him and
there was also
a group of people that really liked him
because so many people hated him and
then you looked at the people that hated
him and you're like
oh these people are really surfaces
my wife really weird my wife was like
here's the problem with democracy she
attacks it from a political standpoint
and and
structures good arguments so you can
listen to him but other people are just
like
he's a racist bigot xenophobic caused
all this and you know
these people are idiots maybe i'm going
to listen more to what he's saying right
than these people and and that's what
what most of it was
when when you when you looked to the
prominent progressive and liberal
personalities in the country they
couldn't offer up a compelling argument
against trump
yeah and so you got people who are
sitting back in their chairs laughing
at what they found to be a a comedy
central style roast of the political
establishment
you know trump was just going at the
political establishment making fun of
them
attacking them insulting them and for so
many americans it felt
good was it michael moore i think called
trump a human molotov cocktail
and he said to all of these people what
trump is saying it's like music to their
ears
and on november 9th 2016 they're going
to the voting booth
and they're going to send the biggest fu
to the political establishment
ever in the history of humanity and he
was right he got
the next part wrong he goes and they'll
be happy
for a week maybe a month and then
they'll realize like the people who
voted for brexit
when in actuality people were extremely
happy for quite some time
do you know how good your michael moore
impression is i can do great impressions
man
i can shut my eyes do more go do more i
want to
i can't do it now it's so good come on
just stop your inner sensor and just do
it no
no there's nothing so good so i if i
why do you feel like i'm like dance
monkey no no i'm not i'm not such a good
i'm not actually good enough the best
michael moore i've ever heard i'm not
good enough
to do impressions on cue i can flow into
it in a conversation and then
invoke like what i remember of them if i
practiced i could probably
all right practice because it's really a
skill that you might excel at
yeah impersonation yeah uh he was right
man people
like they watched trump and it just felt
good he was throwing he was a human
molotov cocktail being thrown into the
system
and he made people laugh the pacing of
the michael moore impression is perfect
yeah it's just i'm not gonna put you on
the spot but i think like for
for your content afterwards i think it
should just be you as michael moore
i should i should do more so good voice
over for uh freedom tunes yes
it's good practice yeah yeah yeah but
anyway you know we got into the subject
of trump and it's kind of like a a
post-mortem i guess in the trump
presidency and where we're at these days
joe biden is stumbling downstairs he's
uh giving
kamala harris all of the jobs she's
calling foreign leaders she's dealing
with the border crisis
i said this i said joe biden he's going
to win
they're going to put him in his
wheelchair they're going to put the
little blanket on his lap and they're
going to wheel him into the sunroom and
he's going to
go and then annie's going to come in and
daddy warbucks will be there too
biden's going to be sleeping in the sun
in the study and commonly harris is
going to be like let's get to work
yeah and that's basically what we're
getting he tries to run up the stair
stairs to make it seem like he's
look man joe doesn't need to convince
anybody that
he's he's young because he's not he's
almost 80 years old
bro just walk up the stairs he tries to
like walk upstairs and he falls three
times
right he tried to like you know sort of
rustle up the stairs i don't want to say
run but like move more quickly like jog
hustle hustle hustle yeah it's tough to
do on that plane yeah and then he falls
over
and then they said it was windy he's
falling up where's the wind you know
you know when the wind knocks you off
the stairs right yeah when you when
you're
right in florida in the midst of a
tornado just standing outside trying to
sleep with your cousin
you know what actually i wonder if
someone if there's someone who's good
enough at vfx they could add a tornado
background to that video
and show the wind and like chairs chairs
flying maybe a cow or two
i read today that i did not know this
and maybe you can shed some wisdom on
this kamala harris does not need to
salute
anybody i saw that as the vice president
is that normal or what i don't know i
don't know if it's
it must be because of that office
because she's not military
is that why it is i don't think she's in
any kind of command i don't think he's
part of the military
he has to right biden has to i don't i
don't know if he has
no he's a commander he doesn't have to
yeah it's like respect i guess
it seems like they get no respect yeah i
don't know i think kamala harris is is
the is the acting president and when you
wait look there's reports that she's the
one talking to world leaders
she's now in charge of the border crisis
what is biden doing
he's complaining about guns on tv i
guess yeah
he shows up i i i love seeing
the trouble at the border and just
knowing that it wasn't the last
president's fault
only and just their fault these are
these are bigger
places and they're more comfortable to
keep these migrant children that we've
separated from their families
the whole the whole just own up to it if
they just owned up to it
wouldn't you and wouldn't other people
go hey now we can listen to what they
want to say like wouldn't it level the
playing field first
is what we were talking about with black
panther and if we had a
you know black president what they could
get away with they
weaponized their own problems against
trump
barack obama created these facilities
trump inherited them
and then they blamed trump while posting
photos from the obama administration
then trump shut them down this is crazy
trump shut down some of these facilities
biden reopened them yeah apparently
kamala harris was protesting out in
front of one of them
and then reopened it it's amazing how
that works right and
uh what do we get now there's like this
really cringe video of a woman singing
part of your world by the little mermaid
song
but it's about joe biden i watched
literally two seconds and i was like i
can't watch your head exploded and you
just fell over and i was just like i'm
not gonna i'm not giving this two
minutes
yep i didn't even have time to take a
nap today and i was all excited to get
here and i'm like i don't have the two
minutes
to be fair well actually no i was gonna
say to be fair the wright does have
their meme videos of trump but i gotta
be honest the meme videos of trump were
actually funny
like you ever see the one where i think
it was carpe dongdam where it's the time
magazine cover
and it says trump 2024 trump 2028 trump
35 30 and it keeps going
and then it shows trump dancing and the
number keeps going yeah they all freaked
out it was hilarious
there's the one where trump's doing that
weird dance where he does the weird fist
thing
white guy dance and it's like playing
that song or whatever those were funny
the memes were funny they were
ridiculous but the meme like the things
they're doing now
the democrats about biden it's like i
liken it to this
you ever see uh uh like pure flex or
like old really really low quality
christian versions of superheroes and
stuff
bible man and veggie tales and stuff i
think so
that that's basically what the the left
has become hollywood and the tv industry
the democrats are this like low quality
unhip
facsimile of actual fun mainstream
culture
the puritans have taken it over and now
they're producing just
cringe ideology content yeah the message
is more important than
the content but that being said people
seek out genuine thought and genuine
entertainment more so than they used to
people are more aware of their choices
right yeah yeah
yeah and it's a lot of reruns a lot of
older movies newer movies
man i tell you it's shockingly bad stuff
i had
we have an artist named matt miller he
does all of our artwork like these wuhan
shirts and stuff and i'm not trying to
plug them but i'm just telling you how
innovative he is he worked on this movie
that was about
the stuntmen that did a jump and
on their car was a confederate flag
because it was modeled after the dukes
of hazard thing the movie's gone they
pulled the movie
from everyone because the confederate
because there's a confederate flag
on a car in a movie can i maybe i should
just
fund a short film or maybe like a
feature length just a really low budget
but like
a well lo well done low budget that just
is like
the anti-locust of anti-woke i i think
we should
first of all i'll do it with you but
lose the idea of very low budget
and at least go to medium budget but
what's medium budget because i'm i mean
like low budget isn't 150
k we could make that's what i mean
absolutely
low budget could be like now you could
shoot a movie on a phone it'd be crappy
but
150k we make like an 80s style totally
raunched
on pc movie uh my buddy zach nguyen had
this idea too
could it be like a buddy cop film it
could be whatever you want give me 150k
i got the people we'll put it together
let's make a move
man let's do it script come on you're
antiquated
yeah we've thought about i mean i had
the money we were
right before covet we're gonna do a
cancel culture movie and we were gonna
cozy up to the guys that were canceling
online
and pretend that we weren't gonna do a
bad thing and then we're gonna cover
shane gillis and cover all these people
and then hopefully find you know all
these canceled people have
horrible skeletons of their closet i
don't know if you know what drives them
yeah but they're yelling loudly to cover
up
what they're hiding were you gonna
you're gonna do like a fictional
movie no we're gonna do a dock because i
did a dock called 25 sets where i did 25
shows in a night 25 stand-up shows at
night and then
uh james altucher who uh owned stand-up
new york was like let's do something
else and we came up with this
camera we've been trying to get him to
come on the show too but james is great
i'll talk to him
yeah trying to i mean we should need a
fine schedule for all this yeah he's in
florida now because
he said new york is dead yeah and then
he got out of there
real quick and i love james and then you
remember seinfeld was like no it's okay
i can see it from the hamptons
yes uh
that's trump doing seinfeld yeah
see i'm not as good at impressions as
you i really just want to hear there's
only
there's only some that i'm really good
at yeah but um i guess a decent amount
yeah yeah it's a great skill to have
uh but yeah we should we should
definitely do an
over the top on pc 80s style ranch
remember porkies where they're like
looking through the hole and the girls
are changing
i don't know that one oh porky's was a
classic and it was shot in canada too
that was like yeah that was one of the
remember there was movies where you're
like oh
tits and you were so excited i was just
born
in the late 80s were yeah i was born in
86.
sorry i was born in 72.
uh so you got to grow up with all that
craziness they were hot dog
these are movies you i i will watch
black panther
if you watch hot dog and porky's fair
deal
all right hot dog was great it's a ski
movie and there's like a stereotypical
asian guy he's like oh he's so scared to
ski
and then that's how he talked i'm doing
an impression
and then uh but you just seem like oh
boobs like hot tub scenes and you're so
excited for boobs
yeah i i've seen what was fast times
that was the 80s right yeah
fast times was pretty good great
soundtrack let's do it let's let's let's
make a uh uh stereotypical 80s anti-woke
all right we get uh maybe we even get
ryan long involved definitely
yeah yeah he's we're we're working
together on the hour pillow project
and we'll see if we can we can get it
together and we'll see how it plays out
because i don't know if the the pillow
thing's actually going to end up
happening
for like you know the good pillow yeah i
think the news cycle kind of had its
rants course but we have that burlap
sack over there yeah i see it full of
packing peanuts it's very funny
so we're uh you know we're thinking
about it it's got it's super topical so
it only really works if david hogg
actually does start a pillow company
yeah and i'm not sure he's actually
gonna do it
but if he does then we're gonna have the
communist version of my pillow that's
great
yeah do you feel uh
when you look at a school shooting like
that one
uh that grabbed so much notoriety for so
long
i go down to florida twice a year we got
like a little condo there and i go down
and do comedy a lot
my wife came with me and she did a
parkland joke
10 minutes outside of parkland and the
whole crowd turned on her it's all like
they were mad they were offended i think
is the best way to put it
and she's like what's the problem
whenever she opens for me she inevitably
walks some of the crowd or just defends
them and doesn't understand why i don't
want her to open for me
uh so her name is christine me and berg
by the way she's very funny
and i'm just wondering do you think in
the cases of these school shootings
where a school shooting happens
is that neighborhood then safe for 30
years after
would you send a kid to that school if
you go hey i'm going to move down to
parkland now because i think it's out of
the way
definitely not you think i think they're
gonna overreact and create overbearing
laws and panic and it's gonna become
nightmarish for the people who live
there you look at like uh
norway for instance and there was a
tragic event we'll call it that
and they mourned and they carried on
because they realized that
we can't control the wind you know what
i mean yeah
in the u.s you get chicago
every weekend every weekend for decades
and they laugh in your face
and insult you when you bring it up they
say you don't really
like it it's remarkable to me that i'm
like hey i'm kind of from this place
and i actually interviewed a black woman
who was leading the charge on protecting
gun rights
getting illegal guns off the street and
advocating for victims of gun
violence they don't care they don't want
to talk about it
and they will tell you to shut your
mouth when you do
but then when you get some you know
these other tragic events that
negatively impact or scare the white
progressive wealthy and affluent suburbs
all of a sudden now they demand you bend
the knee but what happens is they panic
and they create overbearing and insane
rules laws and regulations that don't
make sense
literally don't why do people not care
about black communities poor black
community
it's tribalism that guides everything
the democratic tribe
and i'm not talking about leftists like
socialists who actually want
socialism and they want marxist
revolution or whatever the democrat
tribe
doesn't care about any kind of principle
i learned this at a very early
at a young age when all the democrats
were protesting george w bush and war
the moment obama got elected they were
gone and they were singing and dancing
about obama while he bombed kids
and i was like wow those people lied
about everything and bomb flint
bomb flint yeah what do you mean this
was in a michael moore movie you would
oh
11 9 or whatever yeah so was there any
truth to that
or am i just way off base and that's a
but michael moore is genuinely nuts he
thinks donald trump got elected because
of gwen stefani yeah and his
doc i'm not kidding he says gwen stefani
got paid more money and trump got mad
so he used a presidential campaign run
to boost his salary
so that he could go to nbc and claim now
that he's a president
presidential candidate they should pay
him more wow the reason that's psychotic
is that donald trump registered
make america great again years like i
think four or five years before he even
actually announced his run
yeah everybody knew he was preparing to
run and he even talked about running
back i think 2000 for the reform party
or something
so michael moore has just gone totally
crackpot yeah but
the example cause i've been talking
about gun control a lot they come out
and they're like because of these events
we got to ban the ar-15
and it's like bro that's just like
saying ban gun it doesn't mean anything
bana air 15 what ar 15 what caliber
what kind of what are you talking about
when you say that because there's a
bunch of other semi-automatic rifles
that are functionally the same
that aren't ar-15s so basically they're
coming out and they're telling you to
ban something that won't
change anything they're complaining
about it is just an overbearing
like reaction to a crisis so to your
question
i would not send my kid or move to these
neighborhoods they're gonna have laws
like
you can if the cat sneezes it's a 20
fine and you're going to be like what
you're going to be like it's the law
and because they panic that's the knee
jerk reaction is to
make people more afraid thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time